so last time we started talking about
lidar and
as usual it's we're going to follow the
same theme as as the other chapters
which is uh basically uh we start from
the physics and when it comes to the
physics
the the principle of operation of lidar
is shown in this picture which is the
exact same as other two sensors that we
talked in the previous chapters which is
radar and and sonar so you have some
source and the source sends out some
waveforms to the environment the
waveforms hit some targets part of
energy Echoes back and then the receiver
part of the sensor captures some of that
Echo energy and converts that to
electrical signals and then we process
the signals to basically do do sensing
now specifically for the case of lidar
um when it comes to basically this this
principle the source that is used for
lidar is is a Laser Source right and
then there's always some Optics and by
Optics we mean some uh lens components
or lens assembly uh that that helps
basically uh kind of like shape the the
the the the beam uh uh pattern uh to
something that is useful for for lidar
and uh so so that's basically the the TX
Optics that we have and then you get a
usually a very collimated beam that that
goes through the environment uh so
that's the the the transmitter laser
beam and it hits the target and again
part of that energy Echoes back and then
on the receive side we again have some
Optics meaning uh one or a few lenses
that helps capture this uh uh basically
echoed light and that echoed light is
being shined on a photo detail vector
and what the photo detector does is it's
basically converts photons to electrons
for you so the input is light right
light goes in
and some current comes out electrical
current comes out
and we'll talk in in great detail about
the physics of photo detectors but out
of here you basically now are back in
the elect from Optical domain to the
electrical domain and you can do the
usual thing basically pass this through
a DSP to convert it to digital I'm sorry
pass it through an ADC to convert it to
a digital signal
and then you can do your digital signal
processing on it to basically detect
what you're interested in
um
so again the principle is the same time
of flight right so you measure or the
sensor measures the round trip time of
flight Tau and the range for instance is
calculated by multiplying uh Tau over 2
by the speed of light c
um and uh also for the case of lidar as
as we'll see most lidars not all of them
but most of them work with these like
very highly collimated pencil-like beams
um so uh basically you can safely assume
that that beam Only Hits at most one
Target in the scene so all the echo
signal that we receive back you can
always make the assumption that it's
from just one Target and that will a
makes your DSP a lot easier because for
instance in radar because the radiation
patterns are typically very wide we
could not make that assumption
there's almost always multiple multiple
targets echoing back for radar but but
also it makes the direction of arrival
estimation almost trivial for lidar
because basically the DOA is the angle
you were pointing at so this angle Theta
here
uh which you usually scan so there's
some scanning mechanism that that that
uh basically uh does like a raster scan
of the beam as we'll see so you just
basically read back where was I pointing
to what was the angle I was pointing to
and that is your your DOA so there's
essentially most of the time almost no
signal processing required when it comes
to DOA estimation in lidar so again you
should expect much less or much lighter
DSP in the case of slider as as as as
we'll see but uh so the equivalent of
basically this part
in the case of the radar was just an
antenna right
in radar we had antennas that would
radiate out a electromagnetic uh uh Beam
for us and also on the receive side in
the case of radar we also had antennas
so remember antennas could could operate
as both transmitters and and receivers
of of electromagnetic waves but uh same
was true for sonar so the sonar
transducers mostly uh can operate
bi-directionally both as a transmitter
and a receiver but for uh lidar it's not
the same
um so a Laser Source cannot act as a
receiver and also a photo detector
cannot act as a transmitter so you need
completely separate devices to do
transmit and receive in in Optics that's
important is the principle of operation
clear
okay so we're going to do the usual
thing start from the physics we'll talk
about lasers we'll talk about lenses or
Optics we'll talk about these collimated
laser beams we'll talk about how you
know the scanning works and we'll also
talk in detail about photo detection
principles and devices that are used and
at that point we can complete you know a
system level description of what a
lighter should be like a block diagram
like thing that you have seen in other
cases and then we talk about waveforms
and Signal processing okay so uh let's
get going so what is what is a laser
beam so uh it's it's actually not
different from RF waves so it is also
electromagnetic radiation so all the
physics of of electromagnetic waves that
we talked about for radar also apply to
lidar like they're governed by Maxwell's
equations and things like that the main
difference is frequency or or wavelength
which which are related as as we know so
frequencies just speed of light over
wavelength so at lidar we operate at
much much higher frequencies compared to
radar so radar remember it was like at
tens of gigahertz right 24 gigahertz 77
gigahertz lidar typically operates at
infrared frequencies which are hundreds
of terahertz so you are like four or
five orders of magnitude higher in
frequency which means much smaller
wavelengths uh that that we're working
so that's basically the main difference
but it's the same physics essentially
again it's electromagnetic radiation at
a different frequency but what happens
which is interesting is at these higher
frequencies or shorter wavelengths
basically you can use again things like
lenses to make really really narrow
beams so that was a challenge for radar
right so for radar to make highly
directional antennas you need these very
big dishes basically like parabolic
antennas or very very large mimo arrays
to make like pencil like teams as we saw
and and that's not uh practical for
Robotics and other applications and
radar they can use those antennas but in
robotics you have to you know Sport with
small apertures which means radiation
patterns are very wide not the case for
lidar at these frequencies you can
easily you know super uh laser focus
basically your beat
um and again that that this makes the
DOA estimation almost trivial and and
lidar but again remember that it's the
same physics so you have a magnetic
field H you have an electric field
either orthogonal and then they travel
in in some some direction uh that is the
direction of the propagation of the beam
also exactly like uh the case of uh
radio frequency waves at Optical
frequencies you also get attenuation as
as you go through air if you're going
through perfect vacuum it wouldn't
attenuate but as soon as you have some
material in the way even if it's just
air you start seeing attenuation now
when it comes to attenuation it's a
highly frequency dependent or wavelength
dependent uh at Optical freq at Optical
wavelengths so here let's look at this
this plot down here so this shows
atmospheric transmission not absorption
so it's kind of like the inverse of of
absorption that that we're looking at
here so it's a number between zero and
one zero means nothing goes through
every all of it is getting absorbed uh
one is perfect transparency basically
now x-axis is Optical wavelength in
microns so for instance visible light as
you might know it's between like 0.4 to
about 0.7 microns so this this uh and
basically
this here
this would be our visible light
and you know there's I mean it's it's
areas most mostly transparent not
perfectly transparent but mostly
transparent as those frequencies and I
mean as as we know that's that's why we
can see at those those frequencies uh
now uh when it comes to choices of what
wavelengths to use for lidars well first
of all you don't you you do not want to
be at visible wavelengths because then I
mean it becomes just an annoyance you
know uh
you start like shining laser pointers at
every direction that's that's not very
practical so you want to be you know
outside the visible event and then then
you get to basically infrared frequency
so
um frequencies here are our IR basically
and it's usually divided into like near
IR mid IR for IR but most of the
frequencies used for uh uh lidars are
are near infrared basically specifically
there are three frequencies that are
commonly used so there's 850 nanometers
or three wavelengths you can convert
them to frequencies if you want 850
nanometers 905 and 1550. now you might
ask why these very specific frequencies
and it's uh for two reasons one is of
course you want a very high transmission
right otherwise it just eats into your
your your your your SNR basically it it
attenuates too much as it propagates and
as you see all these three frequencies
the atmospheric transmission is very
high it's actually pretty close to
almost one so that's a good thing but
there are other good frequencies right
like or wavelengths you could be like
here or here or here and so on so the
other thing that that makes these uh
three choices very attractive is
basically that the devices and by
devices I mean laser diodes and and uh
photo detectors that you can manufacture
which are cheap and and uh um efficient
and it turns out that at those specific
frequencies
you can fabricate uh very efficient very
cheap devices and that's the other
reason why these specific frequencies
are are very attractive now um
850 nanometer is kind of being phased
out because from a performance point of
view 905 and 1550 nanometer are better
frequencies so earlier lighters like 10
15 years ago used 850 a lot but these
days they're mostly at 9 905 and 1550.
okay so
um is there a better choice like if you
were to choose between 905 and 1550
um is there uh like how do you compare
the two it turns out that there's lots
of trade-offs when it comes to the
choice of wavelength or frequency for
for lidar so specifically 905 it's it's
the most common today
mostly used in direct direct detection
lidar we'll talk about the details of
direct detection but it's it's a type of
lidar
um and uh what's good about 905 is that
components are cheaper like lasers photo
detectors that basically they can they
can be manufactured more cheaply and
also water absorption is lower at 905
and why do we care about water
absorption because it means that if you
have high water content in the
atmosphere like if you want to see
through fog or see through and Rain
905 could help you a little bit because
it's absorbed less by water what's not
good about it is that you get high solar
radiation at that wavelength so a lot of
sunlight has you know energy in in 905
which basically becomes interference for
your lidar
um your uh this the the responsivity of
your photo detectors are a little uh
lower at 905 compared to 1550 and also
there's a a there's regulations on how
much Optical power you can safely
transmit such that it's safe for the
human eye and that's called the maximum
permissible exposure limit or the MPE
limit and that limit depends on the
wavelength or the frequency we also have
that for RF frequencies by the way so we
talked about it briefly when we were
discussing radar now at Optical
wavelengths it turns out that the MPE
level is is lower at 905 compared to
1550 which means you can transmit less
power which is not desirable because
that means lower SNR uh what about 1550
so that is mostly used in coherent lidar
again we'll talk about what coherent
lidar is but it's the you know second
main type of lidar
MPE limits as I said are are higher so
you can transmit more power that's a
desirable thing uh you get less
interference from solar radiation again
that's a good thing you get higher photo
detector responsivity and efficiency
that's also a good thing what's not good
about 1550
components are expensive but note that
this is I think that
when it comes to for instance a
semiconductor devices they always get
cheaper over time so yes today 1550
devices are more expensive than 905
in five or ten years they might be the
same price so always you get you know uh
this uh basically devices become cheaper
as as the the manufacturing processes
become more mature basically uh and the
other thing that's not good well this is
physics this one is again absorption in
in water so as you see here there's pros
and cons and at the end of the day you
should decide based on the based on the
requirements of the application what is
a better choice today uh like what's the
commercial lighters out there most of
them and by most I mean about maybe like
90 95 percent of them are using 905 but
1550 is is getting traction pretty
rapidly
um here's a a more you know quantitative
comparison showing these trade-offs we
just talked about so here you have four
plots and each shows one of the
trade-offs between 1550 and uh 905.
um so just one thing to note I noticed
this morning that in all four plots the
x-axis units are wrong it says microns
but it's actually nanometers so you
should correct that and it applies to
all four so X is again wavelength in
nanometers and this top left one shows
the the basically the the solar
irradiance so basically this is the
spectrum of the the the the sunlight
that you get as a function of wavelength
and it has this interesting curve but
the point is that again at 905 you get
more solar radiation than
1550. so on this metric 1550 again is is
desirable because this means less
interference from the Sun now this
second plot bottom left shows again this
is nanometers uh shows the responsivity
of photo detectors and what responsivity
is is how much current you get out of
the photo detector in amps per one watt
of optical power that's incident on it
so that's the responsibility units is
amps per watt and there's there's two
things to note here one is you need
different devices or different types of
materials at different wavelengths for
instance at 905 silicon devices are best
that give those give you the best
responsibility about 0.6
but if you go to 1550 silicon doesn't
even work so you need more exotic
materials for instance indium gallium
arsenide or in gas that that can operate
very efficiently at about like 0.9 or so
0.921 amps per watt of responsibility
and this also also so so on the
responsibility metric yes it's better to
operate at 1550 but because you need
more exotic materials that's why it's
more expensive so on the on the cost
metric it's it's not desirable again
this could change right I mean these
processes become more mature and cheaper
over time uh third plot is water
absorption
um again as a function of wavelength and
in nanometers and
again you compare the two and at 905
your water absorption is 0.075 per
centimeter and at 1550 it's 10.8 per
centimeter so there is more than a
factor of 100 difference between the two
okay
but practically it's not as big of an
issue as you might think because the
water content in in the atmosphere is
typically very low except in very severe
conditions like dense fog or rain or
things like that so in normal operating
conditions and by normal I mean like I
know California conditions it's fine you
don't you don't care much
um
that came out wrong I don't mean
California everywhere else is abnormal
compared to California just for the
record but you know what I mean
um but but again if if you go to a place
with high humidity or uh fog or dense
fog or rain this this this number can
can can really really degrade the
performance at 1550.
yeah
in San Francisco like it's really foggy
there so yes what did they not use light
on and well they they use Fine Art but
it becomes very limited actually there
is uh uh I'll try to remember there's a
uh there's two interesting blog posts
from two of the companies that operate
at uh in San Francisco one is from waymo
and I think Cruz also has an interesting
uh blog post and they actually show how
much it degrades in in fog and Rain uh
and they show some point clouds from the
lidars and you get a ton of false
positives very close to the to the to
the lidar it it can still kind of sort
of work and I'll show also some examples
hopefully later today uh but in in
algorithms they need to you know detect
that oh this is this is a rainy
condition my light or false positives
are very high and then they rely more on
other sensors like radar and and in
those cases yes
um finally the the last comparison is uh
this maximum permissible emissions again
this is uh such that these limits are
determined by regulatory bodies to
ensure uh we don't hurt human eyes
um by by by too high of an exposure so
there's multiple curves here and each
curve so this assumes you're sending
pulses of finite duration so each each
curve is a pulse duration so this is
like a quarter second uh duration and so
a long-ish pulse and this is a very
short pulse of just 100 femtoseconds and
then the x-axis is energy density not
power right so that's because it's
energy that means a longer pulse you can
send more energy because you spread it
over a longer time and and it's lower
power it's it's a bit of a weird plot to
me I would rather just plot a power
density and just have one curve instead
of multiple energy curves for different
policy relations but for some reason
that's the standard way of of you know
how it's shown in in the in the official
documentation the point is
um so you can pick one of the pulse
durations let's say 0.25 and again the
MPE limit at 905 it's much lower than
the MPE limit as at 1550 and here means
1550 is more desirable on this metric
because you can you can send more power
basically so again this is just to
illustrate that when it comes to the
choice of wavelength there's multiple
trade-offs so it's not an easy you know
choice of oh this is better than that it
really depends on a bunch of things and
that's why both are are being used in
practice any questions
okay let's continue so now we're going
to start talking about laser physics
now uh at this point uh just uh uh full
disclosure uh we're not going to go as
deep as we usually go into the physics
uh because in this case to really you
know get to the the bottom of the
physics it's really beyond the scope of
this course like you need to have taken
a couple of graduate courses in Quantum
Mechanics for instance to really you
know get to the bottom so so this part
is going to be light but still we're
going to talk about useful stuff okay so
what is a laser a laser is a device that
generates a beam of coherent
monochromatic light and what does it
mean monochromatic means single
frequency
so that means pretty much all of the
energy is contained within a very you
know a narrow uh frequency band if you
look at the power spectrum of the light
that's coming out of the device and by
coherent we mean that basically all the
photons that coming out of the device
are at the same well of course they're
at the same wavelength but they're also
traveling in the same direction they
have the same polarization they have the
same direction of travel and and so on
and so forth so essentially a perfectly
coherent light source if you inspected
individual photons coming out of it you
can't even distinguish them that's
perfect coherency they're all the same
in every
metric basically frequency phase
Direction polarization and all that
um
and then the process the physical
process that enables
um a Laser Source it's called stimulated
emission of photons and and we'll talk a
little more about what stimulated
emission is but in order to uh basically
have this process of the stimulated
emission or in order to
build a laser you need essentially three
components one is a cavity a cavity you
can you can think of it as you know as
an empty space that can contain light
and uh at the two ends of it you have
mirrors so light would just you know
bounce back and forth between the two
mirrors and be contained uh within that
cavity so that's what the cavity is then
you need an optical gain medium what
again medium is is it's a special
material it can be as solid as we'll see
or a gas or other types of materials but
what it does is uh it can absorb energy
and then it can convert that absorbed
energy into photons which then become
the laser light and that's what again
medium is and finally you need a source
it can be electrical source Optical
Source or a heat source to basically
couple energy or feed energy into the
skin medium and that source is called
the pump so you need to pump up energy
to the to the gain medium and the gain
medium is contained inside the cavity
and then by some magic it the lazing
starts to happen here's a picture
showing what what a
laser could look like in in practice so
as I said you have a cavity and a cavity
is just some empty space typically and
close between two mirrors so you have
one mirror at at each end and the two
mirrors one of them is a fully
reflective mirror so 100 of the light
basically gets reflected back from this
mirror but the other end is a partially
reflective mirror why partially
reflective mirror because if both ends
are fully reflective well there's no
laser coming out you need some of the
light to escape the cavity so you can
use it for in practice so so so the the
actual laser beam comes out of the
partially reflective side of the of the
cavity inside the cavity as I said you
have some Optical gain medium we'll talk
more about this and then you have some
mechanism to basically couple or pump
energy into your gain gain medium and
then at the output if you inspect this
laser output
like if you look at the power versus
frequency for instance a power Spectrum
you would see something like this which
as expected it's monochromatic most of
the energy is just at a single
wavelength or it's single frequency so
this one is pretty close not exactly but
very close to 15 50 nanometers and again
y-axis is power in DB and and it's a log
scale so you see like
this this is a very large number right
48 48 DB so
everything is pretty much noise and
almost all the energy is at just that
one frequency and that's very
characteristic of a laser compared to
like if you have something that is uh
not coherent like an LED or a light bulb
and then you look at the power spectrum
of of those light sources you would see
very Broad and it's so broad that I
can't probably even like show it on this
scale of wavelength but it's much much
broader than this because you it it
basically emits uh light at at many
different wavelengths so that's the the
main difference between a laser and a
non-coherent light source uh questions
okay so let's talk a little more about
this stimulated emission and see what it
is and again this is that specifically
that case where we can't go into the the
real like the depth of the physics as I
usually like to uh it's going to be a
little cartoonish but it's still useful
I think to talk about it so stimulating
emission is a three-step process
um what happens is that first
um
as uh you uh pump energy into your gain
Medium as you couple energy into it and
again the coupling mechanism can be
Optical so it can shine light on the
gain medium or it can be electrical you
pass some electrical current through the
gain medium some of the atoms within the
gain medium absorb the pump energy
from again if it's Optical they absorb
energy from the photons if it's
electrical they uh they can absorb heat
for instance and they go into by
absorbing that energy they go into the
an excited
State on those atoms or some of the
electrons and and those atoms go to an
excited state which is just a higher
energy level and
then if you wait some time some of those
excited electrons will just randomly
return to their baseline or ground state
and when they return to the ground state
they release the energy that they had
originally absorbed from the pump in
Optical form so they release that excess
energy into photons and that process
that random process of some of those
excited atoms or electrons come back and
release energy that's that is called
spontaneous emission it just happens
spontaneously
um still there's no lazing this is this
is still there's no coherence there's
there's some random photons basically
getting released in the in the optical
gain medium but then the magic happens
which is the stimulated emission so as
these spontaneously emitted photons are
traveling within the cavity they
interact with some of the other excited
atoms and then they cause them to return
to the ground state and release more
photons okay so they stimulate more
emission basically that's why it's
called stimulated emission but but the
really magical thing about the
stimulated emission is that photons that
are released by this process from the
process of stimulate the commission they
perfectly match the photons that
basically originally caused that that
emission so they they would be released
in at the same frequency have the same
phase have the same direction and have
the same polarization so that's full
coherence okay uh here's a here's a
picture basically showing this
three-step process again uh what what we
are showing here it's kind of like a a
cartoon of the gain medium and the
y-axis here shows the energy level so
before anything has happened uh if if
you look at like any any atom inside the
gain medium it has a number of electrons
and they're at the ground state we call
that the the the the the valence band
and then there is the conduction band
which is empty so none of the electrons
is at excited state yet then you pump it
so you couple some energy and there is
some energy difference between the the
ground state and the excited state call
that Delta e so so that's the energy of
the conduction band minus energy of the
of the valence band and uh it's it's
equal to
um or let's let's talk about what HF is
in the next step so as you pump it some
of these electrons absorb the pump
energy and go to excited state so now
now you have a number of excited
electrons
and then spontaneous emission happens
this is a completely random process some
of these electrons randomly go back to
to their ground state and as they go
back they have to release that extra
energy that Delta e needs to get
released right in the form of a photon
and that Photon what frequency is it at
right or what wavelength is it at uh
again in quantum mechanics it can be
shown that the energy of the photon is
equal to uh basically Delta e divided by
H or Delta e is equal to H which is
Planck's constant
times their frequency
so essentially this Delta e determines
the frequency of the photons that's that
are going to get released so this is
this is a random process but as this
spontaneously emitted photon is
traveling across the cavity it's going
to interact with more atoms and cause or
stimulate them to emit more photons so
now you get two photons for instance by
this process of the stimulated emission
and those photons are going to be
perfectly coherent again they're going
to be at the same frequency same phase
they will travel at the same direction
and they will have the same polarization
so that's that's essentially a
stimulated emission so this is what
makes a laser
and this is the spontaneous emission is
what what makes any light source that
not a laser like incandescent light LEDs
and whatnot those are all only doing a
spontaneous emission uh fun fact is that
again this is just cartoons we are
showing here but if you want to actually
study the physics of it it turns out
that the physics of stimulated emission
at the quantum mechanics level
um it's it's far more straightforward
than spontaneous emission so like if you
take courses in quantum mechanics after
a couple of weeks you would know how a
laser works but it might take you a year
to know how incandescent light works at
the at the physics level it's far more
complicated to explain it but
um this is for us I think this is this
is the level where leave it at here's
another picture again same process but
um
showing it in a different way so here
again we have it we have a cavity so you
have the two mirrors fully reflective
mirror and a partial reflective mirror
if you're pumping it electrically
optically somehow coupling energy to it
and then in the middle you have the gain
medium and this blue circles or say the
atoms in the in the gain medium uh so so
you start with everything at the ground
state as you pump energy some of these
atoms absorb the the pump energy and
they go into the excited state so those
are colored in purple so the purple are
excited atoms and at some point you get
you know more atoms in the excited state
than ground state so that's called
population inversion
and then this random process of
spontaneous emission happens so that's
step three spontaneous emissions some of
these atoms are going to randomly go
back to ground state and release photons
right and then that's the start of
stimulated emissions some of these
photons as they're traveling they
interact with more atoms and cause them
to also go back to ground state and emit
more coherent photons and again so so
it's like a multiplicative effect and as
more and more photons get stimulated
well some of them escape the cavity
because you have a partial mirror here
but some others reflect back and you
know just keep traveling back and forth
between between the two mirrors so
that's how you get the build up of your
stimulated emission and that's why it's
important to have a cavity because
otherwise why put mirrors there you need
the mirrors to contain some of these
coherent photons inside the cavity so
they keep stimulating
more light and then after after the full
buildup you basically get full coherence
and basically all the waves are are
lined up in Phase frequency and
polarization your cavity keeps lazing
you keep all the time you keep pumping
it it's not shown but you can't stop as
soon as you stop the pump because
there's some laser escaping from the
cavity it just dies off so you need to
keep pumping the laser for it to to keep
running but but that's a process
basically so some of these stimulated
emission photons keep traveling back and
forth some of them escape the cavity and
that's basically the laser beam for you
now one thing to note is that so if you
have so these are waves right photons
are waves so if you have a wave that is
traveling back and forth between two
mirrors
um for it to not
interfere and cancel out itself it needs
to add in face and what I mean by that
you just make it more clear is if if you
look at the picture here before looking
at the math so so here is like a
two-dimensional picture of the cavity so
these are the two mirrors so that's
smear
one mirror two
and let's say the cavity has some length
l
now if you have a a wave that is
traveling back and forth between two
mirrors for it to not cancel out itself
the
wavelength of that uh of that wave or
the half wavelength should be or the
cavity length should be an integer
multiple of a half wavelength so the the
longest wavelength you can have such
that it adds in phase is half a
wavelength equals l so you get the two
nulls basically on the two mirrors and
this thing keeps basically like a
standing wave oscillating there the
second one k equals two these are called
the modes or the longitudinal modes of
the cavity is where your wavelength
equals l or you get two Lambda over twos
across the cavity then again the the
nulls are aligned and then this this
thing can just oscillate without
interfering with itself destructively
and so on and so forth so the condition
is the length of the cavity should be
some integer multiple of a half
wavelength and here I'm writing
effective wavelength I'll I'll clarify
what I mean by effective but before that
look at the all the ones down below so
if this condition is not met this is
this one is one example in in in green
is shown here as this wave you know
travels back and forth between the two
mirrors it does not add in Phase with
itself so it eventually it just decays
and cancels out because all these random
phases that that at each point get added
up they just average to zero so a mode
that does not uh meet this resonance
condition cannot lace essentially it
just becomes a non-resonant or a
decaying mode okay so this condition is
a very geometric condition and it limits
what laser wavelengths you can get out
of a cavity of a given length l
okay only only wavelengths that that
basically satisfy the cavity condition
can lace otherwise it just cancels up
so that's one and now what what what is
lamb effective so remember inside the
cavity it's not air it's some gain
medium in there right and that changes
the the
wavelength of the light as you know uh
the the wavelength is affected by the
refractive index of the material uh so
if Lambda is your free space wavelength
then inside the cavity the wavelength is
going to be the effective wavelength is
going to be the free space wavelength
divided by n where n is the refractive
index of the medium so for instance if
your gain medium is made of silicon you
can go check what the refractive index
of silicon is but it's about 3.9 so it
basically reduces your your wavelength
inside the cavity by a factor of 2.9 the
light that escapes the cavity
that is going to be at the free space
wavelength um because because it's it's
going to just travel in free space
um
you can also calculate the frequencies
of these different modes that satisfy
the cavity condition called that F sub K
so as you know frequency is just speed
of light divided by the wavelength and
in terms of the cavity length L you can
write that as K times C divided by 2nl
where we have just plugged in this this
expression for L into here
um and and that's the mode frequency so
again the point is for a given cavity of
a given geometry or length L only
various specific wavelengths
can lazing can happen at very specific
wavelengths it can't happen at every
weight and those wavelengths in or the
frequencies corresponding to those
wavelengths they have a
very you know constant spacing so the
Delta F which is the Delta frequency
between two consecutive modes uh is just
equal to speed of light times two times
the refractive index times l so that's
kind of like the separation of these
modes that that can lace so then the
question is
okay so if we have
these different modes longitudinal modes
that can lace as you turn on your laser
what wavelength do you actually get out
of it or what frequency get out of it
like which of these FKS at the are we
going to get all of them if we get all
of them it's not useful again the point
of a laser is have coherent
monochromatic light if you're getting
like thousands of different frequencies
out that's not mono chromatic it's it's
discrete frequencies but there's too
many of them now practically it turns
out that not all of these can happen or
can can lays why the reason is well
if you look at the cavity
um it's the the material in there it's
it's a gain material but the gain of the
medium is also frequency dependent and
the reason it's it's frequency dependent
it basically uh let's go back a few
slides it's because of what what we have
here if I clean up this slide remember
that there is a energy band Gap
for every gain material and that's a
property of you know the physics of the
material but this Delta e means that
um
when you pump the cavity for instance
the closer your pump energy is to this
Delta e
you're going to get more gain out of it
because that means it's easier for these
electrons to absorb that energy and go
into the the the balance band again it's
a fact from the quantum mechanics you
have to you know energies are but energy
levels are discretized so to take the
atoms or electrons to Exotic State you
have to feed them or pump them with an
energy that is almost exactly equal to
that you know energy gap so that means
the closest your pump energy is to Delta
e you're going to be more efficient in
terms of uh this this gain process and
as you go away from it you just get less
and less and less gain and eventually it
wouldn't even absorb if your pump energy
is too far off from Delta e that's just
the process isn't isn't going to work
okay so here's a picture to kind of
illustrate that so that means this this
blue curve here is like the optical gain
of the medium as a function of frequency
it's going to Peak around some frequency
which is again according to that like
Delta E equals H
um
F
it's going to be most efficient at some
frequency that matches the Delta e of
the gain medium uh the bat this is the
band Gap energy of the gain medium okay
and then so that's that's the game
Behavior so it's you get most gain at
some frequency and it kind of drops but
also as as for any other physical
process you also have some losses so
it's not perfect what are the losses I
mean some of the light just escapes out
some of it it's not you know
spontaneous it's not stimulated becomes
a spontaneous emission there's other
factors that cause losses so so you also
have some cavity loss level okay and for
a mode to lays in addition to satisfying
the cavity condition that geometric
condition that L is K times Lambda over
two also for those frequencies the gain
should be higher than the loss because
if losses are higher just it just
eventually decays and dies off so by
just comparing the gain and the loss you
see only for frequencies where gain is
bigger than or equal to loss those have
a chance of lazing so that would really
limit usually to just a few modes that
can lace and those are called lazing
modes here they're highlighted in green
and again why are these discretized
modes because because of the cavity
condition and if this is Delta F
basically that frequency Delta between
individual modes that can lace okay
so then what you can do in practice when
you design a laser you can engineer this
gain curve and the losses such that this
this g bigger than or equal to l is only
satisfied for one mode and what I mean
by that is just you know you lower your
gain or you increase your losses such
that only for one mode you get g bigger
than or equal to l and then you make a
single longitudinal mode laser and those
are the type of types of lasers that we
want for lidars for instance
for other applications you might want
multi-mode lasers so there there are
actually so for in telecommunications
sometimes you want uh you want lasers
which which have multiple lazing modes
in sensing specifically in lidar it's
very desirable to just have work with a
single frequency uh and and that means
we can only you know when it comes to
sensing look at that frequency and
filter out everything else and really
minimize you know interferences and and
other things and this is again exactly
what you see when you look at the output
spectrum of one of these lasers that are
used used in lidar you just see a very
sharp Peak at just one frequency and
everywhere else is just almost nothing
and that's a single longitudinal mode
laser
okay any questions
all right um
let's continue so in in practice again
there's there's lots of different ways
you can build lasers like when it comes
to the gain medium you can have gases
you can have you know solid estate
things semiconductors and other things
uh the ones that are commonly used in in
lidar are semiconductor laser diodes or
slds and specifically there's two types
of them one is called Edge emitting
laser or eel and the other type is
called vertical cavity surface emitting
laser or vixels
and in principle these are I mean both
semiconductor lasers so that gain medium
is is a semiconductor and everything is
fabricated uh and and one chip uh but
there's two different architectures
um for them basically and here if you
look at the pictures I think that the
difference is is clear let's look at
vixel first so that's the one on the
left
um and and as you see as the name
suggests the cavities is is constructed
vertically so going from top to bottom
at the very bottom you have one metal
contact and both these lasers are
electrically pumped so that's why they
have metal contacts so you can pass
current through it and and pump energy
and then you have some substrate
typically this is like silicon dioxide
or something like that then this kind of
like zebra stripe like thing with
multiple layers that's how a mirror is
built in semiconductor so you stack two
different dielectrics in multiple layer
layers and by controlling the dielectric
constant of the two materials and the
thicknesses you can build an almost
perfect mirror at a given wavelength or
you can build a partial mirror so that's
how mirrors are built very you know
effective mirrors are built in in
semiconductor then you have your gain
medium that's that's this red part here
as a game medium and then on top of the
gain medium you have the partial mirror
again it's it's used by a stack of two
dielectrics and then this yellow part up
top that's your second electrode so
again the Palm current is going through
the the gain medium and from the top
electrode to the bottom and then you
need an opening that's the aperture
where the the laser beam basically comes
comes out of the of the device so that's
a vixel
and then the edge emitting laser that's
the one on the right uh it's a simpler
construction you still have your two
electrodes one at the top one at the
bottom so you can electrically pump it
but the the cavity here is is is is is
vertical so on one side that's the
partial reflective uh mirror that's
that's where the laser beam comes out at
the back you have the fully reflective
mirror and the way the mirrors are
constructed for El is just by cleaving
the facets of the of the device and
there's these cleaving techniques that
can give you different basically
reflectivities also you can coat them to
to control to control the the
reflectivity
um
so vixel is a far superior technology
for a couple of reasons one is as it's
shown here in the pictures the uh the
beams that you get out of pixels they're
more symmetric so they have like a nice
circular cross section versus an uh Edge
emitting lasers you get these like
elliptical cross sections and that is
that's asymmetry is not desired because
this beam essentially is going to
determine the shape of the pixels in
your lidar point Cloud for instance and
you want them to be you know nice and
circular not asymmetric that's not a
desirable property but also uh vixels
have for instance better temperature
stability and and things like that so
there are superior technology but also
they're more expensive
um so they're rapidly again becoming
cheaper and and and and more used in in
lidars but today both are used both Edge
emitting and vixels are used but I think
eventually vixels are gonna are gonna
dominate the the market and then the
specifically the gain material that is
used for these semiconductor laser
diodes is indium gallium arsenide
phosphide which is this very specific
you know mix of uh of of four materials
that that makes a very good gain medium
at these IR frequencies or IR
wavelengths uh questions
Okay so
one last thing about lasers is about the
output characteristic of these
semiconductor laser diodes as I said you
pump them electrically so you pass some
electrical current through it and then
it it outputs a laser for you but it
turns out that there is a minimum
current that you need there's a current
threshold that that you need to use for
your palm for it to lace if you pump it
with less than that threshold current it
actually acts like an LED but as soon as
your current goes above the threshold
then lazing happens and it's it's very
clear if you have one of these devices
and slowly crank up the current that
passes through it it's very clear at
first it's like not very efficient you
get like broad beams out of it like an
LED and as soon as you go above the
threshold the beam you know becomes nice
and sharp and coherent and single
wavelength so when lazing happens you
get much higher efficiency than the LED
regime you get smaller angular spread
your beam becomes more focused and you
also of course in the Spectrum you
become because of that coherence effect
you become uh pretty narrow
about the the longitudinal mode of the
of the cavity
um here's the electrical Behavior so if
you plot basically the the pump current
say in milliamps uh or the output
Optical power versus the Palm current uh
it's very clear if you just look at the
curve uh when you're under the threshold
you know it's less efficient lower power
that's the LED regime and as soon as you
go above it the curve becomes much
sharper it becomes a laser you can it's
more efficient you get more power out of
it and you get all the properties of the
of the lasers one thing to note is that
this threshold current can change with
temperature and that's one of the things
where vixels are better than eels is
that there's less variation in that
threshold current for for vixels
um and and that again is is a good
property for them
Okay so
so then goes
soup it really requires a lot of you
know quantum mechanics related
discussions but you know it it's I think
it's useful to at least know at a high
level how lasing Works what is a laser
what types of laser devices are used for
for lighters now the second topic is
okay so now we have a source a laser how
do you actually illuminate the scene
with this laser right you want to shine
it through the scene and and how do you
do that
um there are two main techniques when it
comes for lidars to use these laser
sources to illuminate the scene first is
called flashlight so flashlight R
basically it's kind of like flash
photography so it diffuses the laser
into a very broad beam exactly like a
like a flash that a camera uses and it
in one shot illuminates the entire scene
with a very wide laser beam and then
receives the Echoes from the entire
scene again in one shot and uses an
array of photo detectors
exactly like a camera to estimate the
time of flight per pixel so flash
lighter essentially works like a regular
camera with a flash except the pixels
and the in the detector give you time of
flight instead of RGB color that's
that's the main main difference
and then you have scanning lidar and
scanning lidar basically the way it
illuminates this this scene it uses very
narrow laser beams like the type of beam
you get out of a laser pointer for
instance and then scans the beam like
does a raster scan of like moving it
around so illuminates the scene one
point at a time instead of the entire
scene all together and
measures time of flight per point so I'm
pointing to that direction measure time
of flight move it measurement time of
flight move it measure time of flight so
it does this scanning thing for you and
because it's Illuminating just one point
at a time it can just use a single Pixel
photo detector just just one photo
detector is enough for it to work it
doesn't need an array here's two
pictures uh showing the two cases so
left is the flashlight are
um and then what it typically has it's
it can work with one laser in principle
but usually they use a laser array and
then in front of the laser array they
also put some Optical diffusers and
that's how they get this you know very
wide laser beam pattern that can
illuminate a very large area
in the scene and then all of it reflects
Echoes back or reflects back goes
through the receiver lenses and Shines
on an array of photo detectors so again
each it's exactly like a camera each
pixel here essentially if you trace the
ray back it's coming from some small
area in the scene and but each pixel the
difference between a flashlight or and a
camera is instead of color it gives you
a a Tau eye or tauhat eye which is the
time of flight for that part of the
scene so it gives you then if you
convert the time of flights to ranges it
gives you a depth map instead of like a
color image so that's how the
flashlighter works and then and then on
the
if I can zoom in on the right you have
your scanning glider
which uses one single laser diode and it
has some scanning mechanism a beam
scanner we'll talk more about it here
it's like a rotating uh polygon mirror
that we are showing so that's how beam
is being scanned and uh basically it it
has some raster pattern here it's going
in rows so it's scanning you know one
row and then another row and then
another row but each row is you can
think of it as you know a bunch of you
know little little points where you
measure the time of flight to and at
each point
depending on where it's pointing again
light reflex back goes through the
receiver Optics and then you just use a
single photo detector just one pixel and
that pixel gives you a time of fly
tauhat which determines the depth to
that one point in the scene and then you
go to the next and then you go to the
next so
scanning lighter kind of builds your 3D
map sequentially versus Flash slider
it's just one shot gives you everything
so uh which is better
um
again there's there's no better there's
there's trade-offs and the big trade-off
here is I think here photography is a
perfect example uh well flash Pro
photography if you want to take a
picture of a very dark scene
flash is very useful
as long as you don't need to see very
far right like flash Photography use
works very well in indoor environments
where you only need to like see a few
meters because all of your energy
because it's being spread across the
entire scene per unit area you have a
lot less Optical power right so so fly
exact same thing applies to flash
lighter so again flash photography Works
beautifully indoors but if you're taking
if you want to take a picture of a
landscape and you want to see hundreds
of meters you cannot use a flash I mean
maybe I mean it would be a flash that
would blind everybody if you used it so
if if you want to be I say if you cannot
use a flash to take a picture you know
out in the wild same thing for lytos so
um actually before we talk about that
here's one picture of what a flashlight
or uses as the Laser Source so this is a
vixel array so each of these little
circles here is a vertical cavity
surface emitting laser there if you zoom
in this is the exact structure we looked
at actually if you even zoom in even
further you see the zebra stripes here
which is which is the mirror
and then it's it's a pretty dense array
so all of this is just one silicon chip
basically
with many lasers on it and then they put
a diffuser and then with that they can
they can get like a flash like very wide
uh laser laser beam
um
in terms of the quality of the point
clouds that you get out of a flashlight
or versus a scanning lighter here's a
here's a comparison so this is a camera
image of the scene it's outdoors you
know there's buildings cars and and and
and whatnot and with the with the
flashlight or this is what you get uh
and and as expected it's very dense you
know
um you can't there's no no scanning
basically it's it's it's uh you get very
high resolution lots of pixels and all
are essentially measured synchronously
in one shot
okay so that's our flashlight or but
then if you do scan this uh or or map
the same scene with scanning lidars uh
you see something like this so here's a
scanning glider which used 16 scan lines
kind of like horizontally going 360
degrees so that's why you get these
rings
and it's a 3D map color means depth here
so it goes from like orange to green or
something like that according to range
so here uh the lidar was kind of like at
the center here
and then it was like scanning like that
but it had multiple multiple you know
scan lines so it did 16. and you of
course get a much much coarser map
compared to the flashlight or uh you can
increase your number of scan lines with
this scanning lighter so here we went
from 16 to 32 it becomes denser but
still not nearly as dense as the
flashlight are okay so from this you
might conclude that okay so flash is
better right like this is a much higher
resolution much denser uh kind of a
point Cloud which is true but again it
only works at Short ranges so that's the
one of the the main trade-offs so when
it comes to scanning versus Flash lidar
that the trade-off is with flashlight
are uh you you get a resolution that is
determined by the photo detector array a
pixel size exactly like a camera right
how many photo detector pixels you have
inside your array and how big they are
determines the resolution it's like a
camera uh you can have much higher frame
rates why because in one shot you're
measuring the entire scene so you can do
it many many times per second so up to
like hundreds of frames per second is
possible but the big big drawback is you
get short range so you can barely get 10
15 20 maybe close to 50 meters but
really not beyond that with flashlight
or why because remember the amount of
energy you can emit is capped by the if
I safety limits and with flashlight R
you are spreading that energy budget
that you have across the entire scene in
one shot so you just can penetrate less
depth your energy is much more spread
exactly like flash photography for the
same reason flash photography doesn't
work at long ranges flashlight or also
doesn't work at long ranges what about
scanning lidar well it's the same
trade-offs basically uh resolution is
depend here the 10 determine by the spot
size of the beam that you're using to
scan the scene and also how fast you're
moving it that kind of determines your
spot effective spot size which is your
resolution in the point Cloud you can
see much longer range again why because
that energy budget that you have you're
using all of it collimated in one beam
so that can go much much further out you
can see hundreds of meters four five
hundred is is is is reasonably easily
doable uh with with that with a scanning
lidar but it's going to be slower again
because you're now sequentially
measuring one point at a time and to to
scan the full scene it just takes longer
than flashlight or so frame rates are
typically less than 30 frames per second
10 10 FPS is typical what you get from
like a commercial lighter today usually
that's that's what to expect 10 FPS
so who's better I mean depends right if
if your application is does not require
to see very long range
and uh but for instance it requires very
high frame rates you should go with a
flashlight on if your application
requires to see very long range but you
can give up uh frame rate then you
should go with a scanning lighter most
of the lidars on the market today are
are scanning lidars and the reason is
the lidar market has been very driven by
um the the basically the efforts along
the lines of self-driving cars or
autonomous vehicles which require long
range which means basically scanning
lidar is a is a is the right
architecture for them but I mean
flashlight are in certain applications
it can work much much better again like
if you're operating in a mine or I don't
know inside forests and you don't need
to see that far but you need better
resolution higher frame rate flashlight
or could be the choice any questions yes
YouTube flashlight on timer flight
camera
it's it's essentially the same it's yeah
I think it that's that's just a
different way of what I'm calling it in
time of flight camera is a camera where
per pixel it gives you essentially time
of flight flashlight or is the same yeah
yeah they might work at different
wavelengths but flashlight are works at
at IR yeah
okay uh next topic is uh so when it
comes to the scanning lidar which is uh
more common type of lidar to use for for
autonomy uh we need to talk about the
type of you know this this collimated
beams that come out of the the lasers we
need to talk about the physics of those
and what happens to them as they
propagate so that's the topic of of
gaussian beams that we're going to talk
about
next now when it comes to laser beams
um the way at least I used to think
about them before I I learned about
gaussian beans was that if you have a
laser diode you get this you know so
let's say this is your semiconductor
laser diode and there's this this beam
of Light Beam of laser coming out of it
and it's just like perfectly collimated
there's just like this pencil beam
coming out essentially
going forever I mean it will get
attenuated but it stays perfectly
collimated well it turns out that that
is wrong it's not how collimated beams
work every physically realizable beam
uh it's going to have regions where it
it basically is converging and regions
of of propagation when it's diverging
um so if you take a beam that is in this
slide going from left to right and call
that Z Direction that's the direction of
propagation every physically realizable
beam it's gonna you know have some
region where it's converging and then it
reaches some Focus plane where that's
the kind of like the minimum waist size
of the beam and then after that it is
going to start diverging okay and that's
that this is this is the fact that any
beam that you can physically make it's
going to have this property
um
for instance we have talked about plane
waves before and plane waves don't do
that but we also know plane waves are
not physically realizable beams those
are kind of like a mathematical
idealization that helps us you know
analyze certain cases and what
determines like is is the beam going to
converge or diverge or is it at the
focal Focus it's actually the if you
look at the wave fronts and wavefronts
remember their surfaces of constant
phase of the electric field so if you
look at the these constant
phase planes which are called the phase
front or the wave front if the
wavefronts are concave that means the
the beam is going to converge and then
when it comes to focus you get a flat
face front and then after that you're
going to get convex face fronts and that
means your beam is is diverging why is
that because always you know locally the
direction of the wave travel is
perpendicular to the face front
or wave front so that means if it's
concave the beam is going to converge
and if it's convex it's going to diverge
and that's how every every beam works so
we need to build a physical model or a
mathematical model to be able to talk
about these focused beams and then that
would enable us to talk about basically
beams used for lidars
um there is extremely useful
approximation to how waves travel which
is called The paraxial Wave the paraxial
wave approximation and this really
really simplifies the math when we want
to talk about Focus beams so what the
paraxial wave approximation says is that
again if you have a if you have a wave
that is say traveling in some direction
and call that the Z Direction okay the
z-axis is the axis of propagation uh it
says that if if you look
far enough down the the axis of
propagation of the wave any kind of wave
you can approximate the electric field
uh as some envelope call that U which is
a function of x y z the coordinates
times a plane wave that is traveling in
the Z Direction which which we're
writing as e to the minus J Norm k z
okay let's look at this plane wave first
if you remember we have looked at plane
waves a few times with plane waves are
always given by e to the minus J the
wave Vector times R which is the
position Vector the dot product so why
are we writing it as as this well the
reason is again we are assuming the wave
is traveling in the Z Direction so the
wave Vector is just Norm k z hat and and
R is X x hat plus y y hat plus z z hat
so if you take the inner product of this
K and that r that just gives you Norm KZ
so that actually is a plain if traveling
in the Z Direction and then you have
this this this envelope which the
envelope just determines the you know
how the amplitude or the intensity of
that wave or or or or light beam changes
at different places in in space
um specifically in the in the paraxial
limit as I said it's the limit where
you're you know far along in the z-axis
the direction of the the the propagation
of the light so the the paraxial
Assumption uh assumes that the Z is much
larger than X and Y so we are just you
know looking along the direction of of
the travel far along uh the travel
Direction uh you know just just just
around the main axis of of the travel of
the light so Z is much bigger than X and
Y which means you can approximate Norm
of r at any point that that is along the
direction of the travel which is square
root of x squared plus y squared plus c
squared because Z is much larger than X
and Y you can approximate it by this
expression and this is nothing special
it's just that the first order Taylor
series expansion to square root of like
1 plus v or one plus X which becomes 1
plus v over T so with that Norm of R we
can write it in terms of x y z as Z Plus
x squared plus y squared over 2z so
let's apply this dysparexial limit say
to a spherical wave I just want to show
you that the the paraxial wave
approximation always works and and is a
useful thing so it's a spherical wave in
general as you know it's given by this
expression this we have seen multiple
times like e to the minus J Norm K Norm
r divided by Norm of r that is the
definition of the spherical wave but now
a spherical wave in the paroxyl limit if
if we apply the thing that we just
derived you can write it or approximate
it with this which is 1 over Z times e
to the minus J Norm K times x squared
plus y squared over 2z times e to the
minus J Norm k z yeah all I did here I
just plugged in if I go one slide back I
just plugged in this expression for Norm
R into my spherical wave basically
equation and if I clean this up
if you inspect this closely it's exactly
what we say the the paroxyl wave
approximation is called the spot your U
of X and Y and Z and this is your plane
wave
so this is just you know I mean we
didn't do it for a a general wave but
you know for for spherical waves it's
very easy to show for instance that this
thing this thing holds uh but it's a
true fact again for any any type of way
if you can apply this paraxial wave
approximation if you're far along the
axis of of the propagation and again
your U is given by by this expression
here now this was for spherical waves we
can we can make this more General and
the generalization you can do is replace
the Z here uh by a complex Factor Z Plus
J times B okay
um and and we'll see what this p is but
here is just a generalization so if
you're substituting Z with a complex
parameter called that Z plus b uh then
the envelope for instance becomes
everywhere we had Z we just substitute Z
Plus JB so you get Z Plus JB here and Z
Plus JB here okay now this is
interesting this is what essentially
constitutes a a gaussian beam uh because
if if you look at this this U here and
again we talked about uh Focus beams
this is going to go through you know
converging and diverging regions and a
focus point but if you for for any fixed
Z if you look at this U so if you look
at U of X and Y and any zero fix your Z
so look at the plane that is
perpendicular to the axis of the the
propagation of the wave you just you
know put like a piece of paper and and
look at the the envelope of that field
uh you would see that what kind of a
function is this for for a fixy it's a
gaussian right like this thing
it comes a gaussian function
for any fixed C specifically to make it
even more obvious let's look at the Z
equals zero plane
so you just plug in Z equals zero in
here and look at that envelope part of
our of our approximated wave plugins
equals zero your envelope becomes this
one over JB times e to the minus x
squared plus y squared divided by we
have defined this Omega 0 but that's
just equal to this square root of Lambda
B over Pi just to make the math a little
more simpler this is a gaussian function
right
I mean that's that's exactly a gaussian
function
uh so that's why in the paraxial limit
uh you can approximate uh a a
propagating beam as a gaussian beam
again what is it it's like a plane wave
that is traveling in the in this in the
Z Direction but if you look at the cross
section of the beam either in the field
amplitude or the intensity it has a
two-dimensional gaussian profile and
this should be pretty familiar to you if
you have ever looked at like Shine the
laser pointer on that piece of paper on
a wall that pattern that you see that is
a 2d gaussian it's bright in the center
and kind of tapers off as you as you go
away that's exactly what this function
basically describes so let's look at
this picture again same thing so that's
that's our beam that's that's our
gaussian beam that's that's propagating
and it turns out that at z z equals zero
is actually the focus plane of of the
beam like if you if you check the the
the beam waste as a function of Z it and
you minimize it it happens to be at Z
equals zero so that's and again if this
was like a laser pointer
laser kind of like pointing in in some
direction and you put like a piece of
paper uh this is this is the kind of
pattern you see like that red you know
uh 2D gaussian pattern that's that's
what you see
um there's two important parameters
about it uh one is as it propagates
again it's it's gonna after its focus
point it's going to diverge okay now how
fast and and the Divergence it's it's
described by uh this parameter W of Z
which is which is the beam radius what
is w side at every Z point if you look
at the distance from the axis of
propagation
uh over which the intensity of the light
drops by one over e that distance is
called W of C that's called kind of like
the the radius of of your beam uh and it
increases as the beam travels according
to this expression I didn't go through
the derivation of this it's in the notes
but I thought that's that's a bit too
detailed for for the for the lecture
um but that's your
beam radius
and what's important about this is again
it's it's going to increase as beyond
the the the beam waste it's going to
increase and uh so and that's determined
by by this Z
but one parameter you can Define is this
angle of
uh Divergence which which I'm calling
Theta D here so that angle kind of also
determines like how quickly your beam is
is uh uh diverging and it turns out that
this angle is almost equal to Lambda
over Pi
Omega zero and what is Omega zero Omega
0 is like your minimum waste like at the
focus Point what is the waist radius of
your uh beam
and then your angle of Divergence is
inversely proportional to it so the very
important Point here is that the sharper
or the smaller or the tighter you focus
your beam the quicker it's going to
diverge
um and and that's uh going to be an
issue when it comes to to to lidars so I
just want to quickly illustrate this
here I have a I have a red laser that is
coupled to a fiber so if I turn this on
so you see it became red so so fiber is
just you know just a glass waveguide and
the
for the entire length of this yellow
fiber the laser is entirely contained in
the fiber so that limits this beam waste
to the diameter of the core of the fiber
which is just 10 microns okay so at the
tip of the fiber you can think of this
point here if I clean up my my slide
this is going to this plane is the tip
of my fiber right that's the kind of
like the focus point of the of the beam
and after that it's going to diverge and
it's a very tight Focus right it's just
10 microns so if I put a
paper very close to this you see it's
it's a very tight
beam I don't know if it if you see it
well or not but see how quickly it
diverges as I go away
see it just blows up very very very
quickly like I'm I'm a few inches away
and it's already you know blown up first
you kind of see the tip of my fiber is a
little dirty so that's why it's not like
a perfect gaussian but it's kind of a
gaussian right it's a 2d gaussian and
it's very quickly diverging and that's
the problem right I can't use this for a
lidar because if I'm a meter away look
how big that spot is I can't work with
that if I want to see hundreds of meters
right and that is why we need Optics we
need lenses that basically take this
beam that is diverging very quickly this
could be this is a fiber but you can
think of it as a laser diode same thing
these are small devices they make very
tightly focused beams that come out of
them but they diverge very very quickly
so that's why you need lenses to to
collimate them I'm just going to take I
know we're almost over time but because
I brought toys I'm just going to take
one more minute and complete this
experiment what I have here
is it's just a lens I mean it's it's a
metal housing but there's a lens in it
and that lens is designed to basically
collimate the beam that's coming out of
this fiber so if I hook up my fiber
to this without breaking anything
because these things are a little tricky
okay so now we have a lens in front of
it
and now let's see what happens what the
lens does is it transforms the beam
waste diameter to a much larger so from
10 microns it brings it to about seven
millimeters so you have you get a bigger
beam right
it's like even very close it's like few
millimeters seven millimeters diameter
but see it doesn't it doesn't diverge
now it's now it's more or less actually
it goes through a focus Point that's its
focus point and then after that it it
actually the focus point is a little
further away but it doesn't diverge as
quickly now this beam I can I can now
see on the wall it's now uh a few
millimeters or maybe an inch but from
the bare fiber it would have been meters
and size across I mean if I if I remove
the the lens we wouldn't even see it on
the wall because it's diverged so much
that nothing is getting back to our eyes
basically
this lens wasn't quite designed for lead
red laser it's designed for IR but I'm
using it on red laser that's why it
doesn't perfectly collimate the beam but
you get the point that why we need
Optics and my Optics I mean lenses is
because to control the Divergence angle
of the beam you need lenses and then you
can design those according to your
application requirements if you need
your beam to be a certain diameter at
500 meters you find the right lens and
then use that in your Optics we'll talk
more about it next time and sorry we
went over time but I just wanted to show
you this quick experiment